.
AND THAT IS WHAT THEY ARE
CONCERNED ABOUT.
>> SARA CARTER, THANK YOU.
HERE WITH MORE AS TEXAS
SENATOR TOM CRUISE.
WE GO FROM COURT PACKING TOOL
LEAKING DRAFT POSSIBLE --
POSSIBLE DROPS OF A DECISION TO
DOXXING THE HOMES OF
SUPREME COURT JUSTICES ONLY IN
AN EFFORT TO HARASS, INTIMIDATE
THESE JUSTICES.
I'M NOT SURE HOW THEY'RE GOING
TO BE ABLE TO MOVE BACK TO THE
NEIGHBORHOOD, MOVED BACK HOME,
NOW THAT THIS EFFORT IS GOING
FULL FORCE.
IT SHOCKS ME EVEN MORE THAN
ANYTHING THAT JOE BIDEN HAS
BASICALLY PUT A SEAL OF APPROVAL
ON IT AND SAYING, THEY ARE FREE
TO PROTEST ANYWHERE THEY WANT.
DO YOU THINK YOU BE MORE PRUDENT
AND UNDERSTAND THE DANGER OF
PEOPLE SHOWING UP TO THE HOMES
OF ELECTED OFFICIALS OR JUDGES
OR ANYBODY THAT WORKS IN
GOVERNMENT FOR THAT MATTER.
>> SEAN, YOU ARE EXACTLY RIGHT.
WE ARE SEEING THESE IMAGES, THE
LATEST MANIFESTATION OF JUST HOW
EXTREME, JUST HOW RADICAL THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS GETTING.
THIS DEMOCRATIC PARTY TODAY,
JOE BIDEN HAS HEADED THE AGENDA
OVER TO THE SOCIALIST, NOT JUST
A SOCIALIST, THIS IS NOW THE
MARXIST.
THIS IS THE COMMUNIST.
TODAY'S DEMOCRAT PARTY BELIEVES
IN VIOLENCE.
THEY BELIEVE IN MOB RULE.
THEY BELIEVE IN INTIMIDATION.
JUST LIKE MARXISTS AND
COMMUNISTS, THEY ARE WILLING TO
BURN OUR INSTITUTIONS TO THE
GROUND TO GET WHAT THEY WANT.
THIS LEAK FROM THE COURT IS
FUNDAMENTALLY DESTRUCTIVE TO THE
SUPREME COURT OF THE
UNITED STATES TO THE RULE OF LAW
AND TO OUR CONSTITUTION.
NONE OF THESE DEMOCRATS CARE.
JOE BIDEN WON'T CONDEMN IT, THE
WHITE HOUSE WON'T CONDEMN THE
LEAK.
INSTEAD THEY SIT BACK AND SAY,
IS NOT INTERESTING?
YOU ARE JUST PASSIONATE, AS
NANCY PELOSI SAYS.
AS JEN PSAKI SAID, LISTEN.
THESE THUGS HAVE NO BUSINESS IN
THE PRIVATE HOMES OF ANY
GOVERNMENT OFFICIAL.
THESE SUPREME COURT JUSTICES OR
ANYONE ELSE.
THESE DOGS WHO DOXXED THE
JUSTICES SHOULD BE EMBARRASSED
AND ASHAMED.
BY THE WAY, THESE ARE THE SAME
THUGS THAT ARE FIREBOMBING
PRO-LIFE OUTLETS BEAR THE SAME
THUGS THAT ARE GOING INTO
CHURCHES, DISTURBING CHURCHES.
THEY HATE FAITH, THEY HATE GOD,
THEY HIT THE CATHOLIC CHURCH,
AND IT IS DISGUSTING TO SEE
JOE BIDEN AND THE ENTIRETY OF
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY TURN A
BLIND EYE.
A REPLAY OF 2020, REPLAY -- IN
THIS INSTANCE ONCE AGAIN, THEY
ARE PUTTING POLITICS ABOVE
EVERYTHING ELSE, INCLUDING
PEOPLE'S LIVES.
AND THESE RADICALS ARE INVITING
VIOLENCE DIRECTED AT OUR
JUDICIARY AND DIRECTED AT THE
RULE OF LAW.
THEY ARE BULLYING TRYING TO
INTIMIDATE THESE JUSTICES.
LET'S GO BACK TO THE SUMMER OF
2024 WE HAD OVER 574 RIOTS.
WE HAD DOZENS OF DEAD AMERICANS,
THOUSANDS OF INJURED COPS.
NOT ONLY WERE THEY SILENT, THERE
WERE MANY PEOPLE IN, HAS THAT
ACTUALLY OFFERED MORAL SUPPORT
FOR THESE GROUPS.
AND THAT THE BAIL FUND, THAT
DEFUND AND DISMANTLE EFFORT.
THEN JANUARY 6TH HAPPENED.
PEACEFULLY PATRIOTICALLY MARCH
TO THE CAPITAL, SO YOUR VOICES
WILL BE HEARD.
THAT IS THE ONE RIGHT THAT THEY
ONLY WANT TO FOCUS ON.
THEY ARE OKAY WITH SENDING OR
ALLOWING OR PROVING PEOPLE GOING
TO THE HOMES AND DOXXING THE
HOMES OF THESE JUSTICES.
WHY THE SELECTIVE MORAL OUTRAGE
AND WHY THE SILENCE AS PEOPLE
SEEM SO -- IGNORE THE OTHER 574
RIOTS AND AN ORTHODOXY IN.
I'M TRYING TO FIGURE OUT
THERE --
>> IT IS COMPLETE HYPOCRISY.
YOU SEE THIS IN THE CORPORATE
MEDIA, YOU SEE THIS AMONG
DEMOCRATS.
ON JANUARY 6 OF 2021, YOU ARE
TENS OF THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE
PEACEFULLY PROTESTING.
SLANDERING THEM WITH THEM MADE
UP TERM, INSURRECTIONIST, AND
YET IN THIS INSTANCE, THEY ARE
NOT WILLING TO CALL OFF THEIR
GOONS EVEN NOW, EVEN NOW AS IT
HAS THE POTENTIAL TO ESCALATE.
WHEN IT COMES TO ABORTION,
TODAY'S DEMOCRATIC PARTY HAS
GOTTEN SO RADICAL, THEY SUPPORT
UNLIMITED ABORTION ON DEMAND UP
UNTIL THE MOMENT OF BIRTH WITH
TAXPAYER FUNDING AND NO PARENTAL
CONSENT AND NO PARENTAL
NOTIFICATION.
THE LATEST POLLING SHOWS THAT
JUST 6% OF AMERICANS SUPPORT
UNLIMITED ABORTION ON DEMAND
RIGHT UP UNTIL THE MOMENT OF
BIRTH.
THE REASON DEMOCRATS ARE
FIGURING OUT IS BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T ACTUALLY CONVINCE THEIR
FELLOW CITIZENS THROUGH THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS TO ADOPT
THEIR EXTREME RADICAL VIEWS.
SO INSTEAD THEY WANT TO USE
BRUTE FORCE.
AND IN THIS INSTANCE, THEY WANT
TO USE VIOLENCE.
IF THEY WANT TO PROTEST, GREAT.
GO TO THE PUBLIC SQUARE, GO TO
THE MALL, GO IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT.
PROTESTERS IN FRONT OF THE
SUPREME COURT FROM THE TIME IT
WAS BUILT.
ALL OF THAT IS LEGITIMATE.
BUT THEY ARE NOT LOOKING FOR A
PEACEFUL SPEECH.
THEY ARE LOOKING, INTIMIDATION,
THEY ARE LOOKING FOR TARGETING
THE KIDS OF THE JUSTICES.
THAT IS GROTESQUE.
AND JUST THIS WEEK, WE SAW
"THE WASHINGTON POST" -- THIS
ONE PROTESTER, THIS WOMAN WHO
WAS PROTESTING HER NEIGHBOR,
BRETT KAVANAUGH.
I MEAN IT, IS SHAMEFUL.
AND THIS IS WHERE TODAY'S
DEMOCRATIC PARTY IS.
THEY ARE AFRAID OF NOVEMBER,
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE VOTERS ARE
GOING TO THROW THEM OUT ON THEIR
RERUNS.
>> THEIR ESTATES RIGHT NOW, THE
BIG MYTH THAT THEY FROZE OVER TO
HER AND THAT ABORTION WOULD
BECOME A LEGAL IN AMERICA YOU
KNOW, IT WILL NOT.
THE STATES WILL DECIDE, BECAUSE
ROE WAS BAD LAW, FROM MY
PERSPECTIVE.
YOU ARE THE LAW STUDENTS.
ONE OF ALAN DERSHOWITZ BEST.
IN HIS OWN WORDS.
BASICALLY WHAT THEY DID IN THE
CASE OF ROE WAS THEY GRANTED A
RIGHT, NOT GRANTED IN THE
CONSTITUTION, SO I WOULD ARGUE
DOES RATHER THAN GO FORWARD AND
GIVE THAT A RIGHT TO
INDIVIDUALS, THEY BASICALLY SEND
IT BACK TO THE STATES.
THERE IS A WHOLE BUNCH OF STATES
THAT ALLOW ABORTION UP UNTIL THE
HOUR BEFORE BIRTH.
FOR CRYING OUT LOUD.
THAT WILL STILL CONTINUE IN SOME
STATES.
ABORTION IS NOT GOING ANYWHERE.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
IF YOU LOOK AT OUR NATION'S
HISTORY FOR THE FIRST 185 YEARS
OF OUR NATION'S HISTORY,
ABORTION WAS DECIDED BY ELECTED
LEGISLATURES, PRIMARILY AT THE
STATE LEVEL.
AND LISTEN, WE ALL RECOGNIZE
THAT ABORTION IS AN ISSUE THAT
IS DEEPLY EMOTIONAL, IT'S
PERSONAL, PEOPLE FEEL VERY
STRONGLY AND HAVE SHARPLY
DIVIDED VIEWS.
WHEN ROE V. WADE WAS HANDED
DOWN, IT WAS SEVEN UNELECTED
LAWYERS IN BLACK DROVE SAID TO
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU PESKY
VOTERS.
YOUR VIEWS DON'T MATTER.
WE KNOW BETTER THAN YOU DO.
WE ARE PHILOSOPHER KINGS AND WE
ARE GOING TO DECREE THE RULE.
AND I WILL TELL YOU, IT WAS
WRONG WITH IT WAS ISSUED, IT'S
BEEN WRONG EVERY DAY SINCE THEN,
BUT THAT RULING PRODUCED
ENORMOUS ANGER, AN ENORMOUS
DIVISION, BECAUSE WHEN PEOPLE
DISAGREE AND FEEL STRONGLY ABOUT
IT, IF THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS IS
AVAILABLE, YOU CAN GO AND MAKE
THE CASE TO YOUR FELLOW CITIZENS
OR YOU CAN ARGUE FOR IT, BUT
WITH ROE, THE COURT SAID NO, WE
KNOW BETTER THAN YOU DO.
IF ROE IS OVERTURNED, AND I PRAY
THAT IT IS, THE RESULT WILL BE
AT GOES BACK TO THE ELECTED
LEGISLATURE.
HARASSING THE JUSTICES -- THEY
CAN GO TO THEIR STATE
LEGISLATURE.
ALREADY IN FRONT OF THE
LEGISLATURE FOR THE ROLE THEY
WANT AND WILL LET DEMOCRACY PLAY
OUT.
>> IN OTHER WORDS, THERE WAS NO
RIGHT TO SUCH -- THERE WAS NO
RIGHT ENUMERATED IN THE
CONSTITUTION.
AND THEREFORE IT SHOULD
CONSTITUTIONALLY BE IN THE
STATE'S HANDS.
IF IT IS OVERTURNED ON THIS
DRIVE COMES DOWN THE WAY WE
THINK IT WILL, THAT WILL BE WHAT
THE LAW AND EVERY STATE -- EVERY
STATE WILL MAKE THEIR OWN LAW
AND WE WILL DECIDE FROM THERE.
SENATOR, GOOD TO SEE YOU.
WE WILL WATCH VER